[موسيقى]
الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر بتوقيت
الرياض وانا صهيب وهذه اخبار الساعه
سوليدار اهتزت لكنها لم تسقط وروسيا تعد
بمفاجاه باجتماع مجلس الامن المقبل
بريطانيا تحذر نظام طهران من تنفيذ حكم
الاعدام بحق علي اكبر وايران تبرر ساهم
بارتلال العالم النووي محسن زازا
بعد العثور على حزمه ثالثه من الوثائق
السريه بمنزله في دلو» بايرن يؤكد تعاونا
ومكارتي يطالب بالتحقيق
بعد عاصفه الامير هاري العائله الملكيه في
بريطانيا تجذب الانظار بظهور علني غير عدي
[موسيقى]
واسعد مؤقتا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه في
اوكرانيا بتسموا مدينه سوليدار الاكثر
تردد في الاونه الاخيره اهتزت المدينه
لكنها لم تسقط تتارجحوا بين محاولات
الروسيه للسيطره ورغبه اوكرانيه في الصمود
كافه روسيا تبدو ارجع في معارك الشرق
الاوكراني وذلك باعتراف من الجانب
الاوكراني حيث اكدت نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكرانيه انا مليار ان الجيش يقاتل من
اجلدار لكن الوضع صعب في ظل معاركه هي
الاشرس مع القوات الروسيه اما موسكو فقد
بدت منتشيه بالنتائج المحققه في الشرق
الاوكرانيه حيث قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
انه هجومها في منطقه بشرق اوكرانيا مستمر
بنجاح دون الاعلامي عن السيطره على
المدينه
وفي حال سقوطها فين سولدر ستصبح نقطه
انطلاق موسكو للهجوم على مدينه باخمه
الروسيه الى جانب مجموعه فاجر
في السيطره على خطوط الامداد في شركه
اوكرانيا
استمرت الهجمات ناجحه على الدونتس من قبل
القوات الروسيه نتيجه الضربات الجويه
والمدفعيه واصلت خسائر العدو التي لا يمكن
تعويضها الى 70 فردا اوكرانيا ودبابات
واحده وثلاث عربات قتال مصفحه واربع
سيارات
جديد من خلال ما وصفته بفتح اوكرانيا حول
الحرب الدائره بينهما الخطوه ستتم على
مستوى مجلس الامن والذي سيعقد جلسه يوم
الثلاثاء القادم حول الحرب في اوكرانيا
وهذه المره بمبادره من روسيا هذا ما اعلنه
ديمتريه وليليانسكي النائب الاول لممثل
روسيا لدى الامم المتحده الذي اكد ان
الجلسه ستعرف تقديم وقائع وتقارير مثيره
من خلال مقاطع فيديو وصور
[موسيقى]
والحرب في اوكرانيا رفعت من اسهم الاسلحه
بشكل عام حيث ماتت عمله المطلوبه القوات
الاوكرانيه تستفادت من امدادات ضخمه من
الاسلحه سيما من الولايات المتحده التي قد
لا تستمر في دعمها بنفس الوتيره المرتفع
وذلك بسبب حجم الانتاج وهذا ما حذر منه
وزير البحريه الامريكيه كارلوس ديلتورو
حيث اكد ان استمرار الدعم لاوكرانيا سيكون
صعبا اذا لم يكثف صانعه الاسلحه الانتاج
في الاشهر السته المقبله هذا وتعمل وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه عن كتب مع صناع الاسلحه
لزياده في تحفيزهم على زياده معدلات
الانتاج الخاصه بهم سيامو ان حاجيات
المؤسسات العسكريه الامريكيه من امدادات
الاسلحه كبيره ايضا
ووجهت وزاره البحريه الامريكيه انتقادات
للشركات المنتجه المنتجه للاسلحه لعدم
الالتزامها بالمواعد النهائيه لتسليها
ونقلا عن البحريه الامريكيه فان سلسله
التوريد قد تطرب اذا استمر الصراع في
اوكرانيا لمده سته اشهر اخرى وكانت صناعه
الاسلحه في الولايات المتحده قد تاثرت
بشكل كبير بجائحه كورونا حيث توقفت الكثير
من المصانع عن الانتاج لمده اشهر
معنى من واشنطن العقيد عباس دهوك المستشار
العسكري والسابق لوزاره الخارجيه لشؤون
الشرق الاوسط مرحبا بكم على سياده العقيده
الكونغرس الامريكي حتى الان اجازه مئه
مليار دولار من المساعدات العسكريه
والاسلحه الى اوكرانيا
ما الذي يجعل اذا شركات التصنيع تصنيع
الاسلحه في امريكا تتاخر علاوه على مساله
تعطل سلاسل للتوريد بسبب رائحه
مسلسل قديمه
الجيش الامريكي
وفي كل مكان وليس اوكرانيا
الحروب عبر الحدود
وانا وانا
مستغرب ان هذا ليس من
الرئيس
همم الجيش كثير
لكنها لا تضاهي همم
الولايات المتحده وغيرها يعتقدنا الحرب
ستكون قصيره لكنها استمر
تستمر لابد قرار لان همم
انت رفع الانتاج ليس اا سهل بمجرد وضع
التمويل لابد من وجود الشركات والتعاقد من
اجل الحصول على قطع ال ال التي تلزم في
تصنيع سلاح وكذلك الموارد البشريه التي هي
تقوم باشياء اخرى هذه الاولويه
هل هذا التاخير من قبل صانع السلاح
الامريكي سيؤثر على مجرى الحرب بمعنى ضد
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
هذا سيؤثر على العمليه وخاصه
عن همم
يبدو انه يمكن ان يحدث في المستقبل
اثار الاعلان الفرنسي المفاجئ بشان ارسال
المركبه القتاليه المدرعه اي ام اكس 10 ار
سي الى اوكرانيا تساؤلات اذا كانت باريس
سترسل دبابات الى اوكرانيا وبالتالي تغيير
الموقف فرنسا والغرب الرافد لارسال هذا
النوع من السلاح الى ساحات القتالي ضد
روسيا
اوكرانيا قد تستقبل دبابات من جميع دول
اوروبا
بولندا التي وعدت بتزويد كييف باربعه 10
دبابه من طراز ليفرد 2
دبابات ليبرتو المانيه الصنع متوفره ايضا
في اسبانيا وفنلندا وهولندا
المانيا كثيرا ممتنعت عن الموافقه على
التبرع بها لكن ووفقا للرئيس البولندي
اعاده برلين النظر في هذه المساله
بالتوازي تخطط بريطانيا لارسال عشر دبابات
تشالنجر لاوكرانيا
دبابات ليبرتو يبلغ وزنها 69 طنا تضم
مدفعا عيار 120 م
دبابه تشالنجر 71 طنا مسلحه بمدفع بنادق
من عيار 120 ملم
ليفربول
الدبابات في العالم
يتوقع ان ترسل فرنسا مركبات استطلاع اي ام
اكس 10 لاوكرانيا
وهي مركبه قتاليه تعرف ايضا بمدمر
الدبابات
[موسيقى]
وعلى الوضع في روسيا مع تغيير القياده
العسكريه للقوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا نبقى
اذا مع مراسلتنا
وعشرين روسي خلال الموجه الاولى وسط
تقارير اعلاميه وغربيه تتحدث عن امكانيه
بدء عمليه التعبئه بعد انتهاء اعياد راس
السنه في روسيا وفي ظل عدم وجود ضمانات
لعدم اعلانها بسبب عدم توقيع رئيس الروسي
على مرسومه ينهيها اما الكرنب اكد على عدم
صحتها هذه الشائعات وشدد على ضروره
الاستماع فقط الى التصريحات الرسميه وفي
ظل خطط وزير الدفاع الروسيس الجيش ارجوك
زياده حجم الجيش الى مليون و500 شخص تحدث
رئيس لجنه الدفاع في مجلس الدومه عن
امكانيه زياده سن التجنيد في روسيا الى 30
عاما
لا اعلم كيف ستنعكس هذه التغيرات على مسار
العمليه العسكريه اثق ان القائد الجديد
خبير لكن امل ان يكون قادر على العمل مع
الخبراء الاخرين وسينتهي كل شيء بشكل جيد
للجميع
حقيقي
[موسيقى]
كان محتجزانا منذ ابريل 2020 وواحد من بين
عدد من الامريكي روسيا والذين تسعى
السلطات الامريكيه الى اطلاقهم
[موسيقى]
تعمل كله من واشنطن وطوكيو على تعزيز
التعاون العسكريه بينهما مع زياده تهديدات
الصين في شرقي اسيا بالاضافه لتهديدات
كوريا
الى مستوى الفضاء والتصدي لاي هجوم
المحتمل في الفضاء من قبل الصين
لا تقل عن حرب
ساخن تؤجج الوضع وتخلق نقاط تحولا في دول
المنطقه
اليابان التي يحضر دسترها السلمي تكوين
جيشا حقيقي
وتطوير القدرات العسكريه مع الولايات
المتحده لمواجهه التهديدات الصين وكوريا
الشماليه
وجود امريكيون في المنطقه ليس بالجديد اذ
تتواجد قواعد استراتيجيه الرئيسيه وهي
مخصصه للتمركز وقواعد العمليات الاماميه
لتوفير الدعم والحمايه للقواعد
الاستراتيجيه بالاضافه الى مواقع التعاون
الامني وهي القواعد الجويه والبحريه
التابعه للحلفاء
الاجتماعات الثنائيه بين واشنطن تدور حول
التحدي الاستراتيجي الاكبر كما اتفق عليه
الطرفان وهي الصين التعاون الثنائي طال
الفضاء ليتم تمديد الشروط معاهده الدفاع
المشترك وتشمل الفضاء والاستعداد للتصدي
لاي هجوم عبره
الخامسه من المعاهده ما يعني ان اي هجوم
على اي من البلدين هجوم على الاخر
نحن نعمل على تعليق تعاوننا عبر كل
المجالات الفضاء الخارجي مهم لامن تحالفنا
وازدهاره الهجمات على الفضاء او منه تمثل
تحديا واضحه
لا يشبه شيئا من النهج الدفاع والسلمي
الذي لطالما اتبعته اليابان لتزيد ميزانيه
الدفاع خلال السنوات الخمس المقبله وتعزز
قدره الرد ليس فقط بالدفاع بل بالهجوم
ايضا اذا عمر العربيه
طلب المتحدث باسمي وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
بانه لا يضر الاتفاق العسكري بين اليابان
والولايات المتحده لا يضر اذن بمصالح اي
طرف ثالث او التاثير على الاستقرار
الاقليمي وذلك ردنا على اتفاق تعزيز
التحالف العسكري بين واشنطن
لاحظنا التقارير ذات الصله عند اجراء
التعاون العسكري الثنائي يجب على الولايات
المتحده واليابان التاكد من انه لا يضر
بمصالح طرف ثالث او السلام والاستقرار
العالمي
[موسيقى]
قالت وكاله الانباء الايرانيه الرسميه ان
المواطن البريطانيه الايرانيه علي رضا
اكبر لاعب دورا في اغتيال العالم الايراني
محسن فخري زاد في عام 2020
الى السلطه الايرانيه تستعد لاعدامه وقالت
زوجه اكبر ان احد المسؤولين طلب منها
الحضور الى سجنه في طهران من اجل لقاء
اخير وطالبت بريطانيا ايران بوقفه تنفيذ
حكم الاعدام بحق اكبر وقالت انه دوافع
سياسيه
وزير الدوله بوزاره الشؤون الخارجيه
البريطانيه للذكر في قال امام البرلمان
البريطاني ان لندن تدرس تصنيف الحرس
الثوري الايراني منظمه ارهابيه لكنها لم
تتخذ بعد قرار نهائيا بهذا الشان دوكرتي
وخلال مناقشه للوضع في ايران دعا بعض
الاعضاء الى حضر حرس الثوري وقال ساكون
مخطئا اذا قدمت تكهنات بشان نتيجه الدراسه
التي تجريها الحكومه في الوقت الراهن لهذه
القضيه وهي دراسه تجري بجديه يقول وزير
الدوله البريطاني
من لندن معنا احمد ياسين عضو حزب
المحافظين البريطاني سيد احمد اهلا بك
معنا في اخبار الساعه بدايه هل لديكم اي
معطيات اضافيه حول مدار في جلسه مجلس
العمومي البريطاني حول ايران
قدم عضو البرلمان من قبل حزب المحافظين
بوب بلاك مان طلبا مباشره لكي تتم توحيد
جهود جميع الدول الغربيه
مع ايران نزلنا كما هو عليه الان يبدو ان
الدول الغربيه تتعامل مع ايران بشكل منفرد
وقد بدا هذا الوضع منذ انسحاب الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في عهد ترامب من
الاتفاق النووي لذلك الى الان ما زالت
الدول الغربيه تتعامل مع ايران بشكل منفرد
وعلى ذكر الموقف المنفرد البريطاني الحديث
الان على دراسه بريطانيا
لتصنيف الحرس الثوري الايراني على قوائم
الارهاب عندما يقول الوزير الذي ذكرتي
وزير الدوله الخارجيه البريطانيه ان
الدراسه التجري بجديه هل يعني هذا ان
ستدرج قريبا لحرس الثوري في قوائم الارهاب
يعني حاليا هذا الملف هو في طور الدراسه
ويبدو انه ياخذ زخما متناميا
لوضع الحارس الثوري الايراني في قائمه
الارهاب انطلاقا من حال التشنج في
العلاقات البريطانيه ال- الايرانيه ومن
الواضح جدا ان هذه المرحله تعكس يعني اسوء
المراحل في العلاقات بين البلدين انطلاقا
من كون ان ايران قد احتجزت همم
شخصيات بريطانيه من اصول ايرانيه كذلك
ايضا الانتقادات المباشره والحاده من قبل
بريطانيا بخصوص المظاهرات التي تجري همم
في ايران وطريقه التعامل الحكومه
الايرانيه معها كذلك ايضا النقطه الاساسيه
التي ادت الى تدهور العلاقات بين البلدين
هو انقراض في الحرب الاوكرانيه من الواضح
جدا الانسان الطائرات صحيح نعم ولكن سيد
احمد ايران لا تحتاج فقط المواطن
البريطاني من اصل ايراني ولكن هي تستعد
لاعدامه حسب اخر التقارير ماذا لو اعدمت
ايران حقا هذا المواطن البريطاني علي رضا
اكبر
مرضت الفعل البريطانيه وهل ستسارع ايضا كا
اول اجراء ربما لادراج الحرس الثوري على
قوائم الارهاب
يعني بالتاكيد في حال اقدمت ايران على
اتخاذ مثل هذه
سيد احمد
سيد احمد طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال مع
ضيفنا ولكن على العموم شكرا جزيلا لك سيد
احمد ياسين العضو المحافظين حزب المحافظين
البريطاني من لندن
[موسيقى]
اعتبر الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد بان
اللقاءات السوريه التركيه برعايه روسيا
يجب ان تكون مبنيه على انهاء التواجد
العسكري التركي في الاراضي السوريه كي
تكون مثمره وذلك في اول تعليق لها على
التقارب بين الدولتين بعد قطيعه استمرت
احد 10 عاما
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه متسببا بخسائر
كبيره خطا مهندس صيانه وراء تعطل نظام
اشعارات الطيران في الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد خلل متحدث باسم حركه
طالبا الى الكريم في مقابله خاصه مع
العربيه ان حق المراه الافغانيه مصان
بالزواج والمهر وان طالبان منحه المراه
حقوقه لم تكن موجوده بالسابق كما انه من
واجبها تنظيم شؤون التعليم والتنميه في
البلاد وفقا في احكام الشريعه واكد ان
الاماره الاسلاميه ستبحث بانتقادات
المسلمين لطالبان بشان قرار تعليم المراه
نظرانا الاماراتيه تتكون من علماء وطلاب
يهتمون بالعلوم والتربيه والتعليم اكثر من
اي فئه اخرى والاماره لا تعارض تعليم اي
شخص باي شكل من الاشكال ولكنها مسؤوله عن
تنظيم المراحل التربويه والتعليميه وكل ما
يتعلق بذلك فهي مسؤوله وترى ان من واجبها
ان يكون ذلك وفقا لاحكام الشريعه
الاسلاميه
والمبادئ الاسلاميه
وفي افغانستان تتوالى ردود الافعال على
قرار طالبان بمنع الفتيات من التعليم في
الجامعات والمعاهد العربيه التقت بالاستاذ
الذي مزق الوثائق التعليميه تضامنا مع
الفتيات الافغانيات نتابع
[موسيقى]
من الصعب جدا وذم مجهود العمر كله من
الشهادات والوثائق الاكاديميه لكن مشاعر
قويه دفعته الى اخذ هذا القرار الصعب كما
يقول اسماعيل مشعل الاستاذ الجامعي الذي
مزق شهاداته في برنامج المسلسل رد على
قرار طالبانا بمنع الفتيات من التعليم
والدفاع عن اخوات الفتيات الجامعيات الى
ان استطيع واتمكن من الكفاح الذي بداته من
اجل سيدتي اللواتي يبلغ عددهن 20 مليون
فريد احمد من زملائي مشعل في العمليه
التعليميه استاذ جامعي لكنه قدم استقاله
من مهامه التعليميه في الجامعه ايضا يكافح
مع مشعل جنبا الى جنب لاسترجاع الحقوق
التعليميه المشروعه للفتيات
لن نرجع الى مهمتنا المقدسه مهمه التدريس
حتى تفتح جميع باب المدارس والمعاهد
والجامعات امام جميع الفتيات في جميع
افغانستان
اسماعيل مشعل يملك حاليا مدرسه ابتدائيه
ومعهدا وجامعه يقول انه عنتره جميع هذه
المشاريع التعليميه تضامنا مع الفتيات
الافغانيات ويشتغل في مؤسسته الخيريه التي
تقدم خدمات انسانيه
للمحتاجين في المجتمع الافغاني على
ايح فان الاستاذه مشعل ليس نادما على
تمزيقه شهادات لكن صنعه ياتي لوجه رساله
رفضا لقرار منع تعليم الفتيات وهو يعلم ان
ما فعله لن يثني طالبانا عن قرارها قبل
نادر العربيه كابول
[موسيقى]
افادت شبكه واي بي سي نيوز الامريكيه ان
خطا مهندس صيانه كان وراء تعطل نظام
اشعارات الطيران في الولايات المتحده امس
وذكرت الشبكه نقلا عن مسؤولي الامريكيه ان
مهندسا صيانه استبدل وحده التشغيل بنظام
باخرى ما ادى الى تعطل النظام واشار
المسؤول الى ان العطله الذي اصاب حركه
الطيران تسبب بخسائر كبيره
مهند السياده ادى الى عطل نظامي اشعارات
الطيارين كما افاد شبكه اي بي سي
الامريكيه عادت حركه الطيران الى طبيعتها
حيث لم يسجل الكثير من الغاء الرحلات او
تاجيلها حتى على مستوى المسافرين كانت
الحركه عاديه فشركات الطياران تعهد بان
تتخذ الاجراءات اللازمه لتيسير حركه
المسافرين الذين اجل بعضهم رحلاته من
البارحه الى اليوم
[موسيقى]
نبقى في امريكا ولكن في قصه اخرى قصه
وثائق الرئيس جو بيدن حيث حرب الوثائق
السريه اذا تشتعل بين رئيس الامريكي
الخليج وبايدو ورئيس السابق
سريه بمكاني اقامته فلوريدا وجد نفسه في
موقف مشابه بعد الكشف عن وثائق السريه
كانت في حوزته الموضوع لم يتوقف عند هذا
الحد حيث كشف البيت الابيض عن اكتشاف
الدفعه الثانيه من الوثائق السريه كان
يحتفظ بها بيض في منزله بمقاطعته
هذه هي الدفعه الثانيه تم العثور عليها
تحديدا في منطقه للتخزين في مراه منزل
مع وجود وثيقه واحده في غرفه مجاوره واعلن
مستشاره بايضا عن قيامهم بتبليغ وزاره
العدل مباشره بعد العثور على الوثائق وان
محامي وزاره احتفظ بها بالوثائق وتاتي هذه
الدفعه الثانيه بعد الاولى التي تم العثور
عليها في مكتب مركز ابحاث تابع لبيضين في
واشنطن العاصمه وضمت 10 وثائق ووصفت
بالسريه وترجع الوثائق السريه التي عثر
عليها في مكتب بايدن للفتره بين 2013
و2016
وتاتي هذه القضيه في وقت وجهه فيه الرئيس
الديمقراطي تحديات من جانب الجمهوريين
الذين انتزعوا الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب
خلال الانتخابات النصفيه كما ان القضيه قد
تخدم مصالح ترامب في ملف الوثائق السريه
التي عثر عليها في مقر اقامته في مرغو
وبهذا الخصوص كتبت صحيفه نيو نيويورك
تايمز ان اكتشاف الوثائق يطرح تساؤلات حول
بيض الذي كان يفخر بالالتزام بالقواعد
التي انتهاك ترامب فالعثور على وثائقها
السريه في مكاتب تعود لبايدن يمكن ان يؤثر
على فرصه توجيه اتهام جنائي لدونالد ترامب
كما قد يدعم الحادث ادعاءات ترامب بتعرضه
للاستهداف لعرقله ترشحه لسباق البيت
الابيض في
2024 وهو ما يفسر تحركات ترامب الذين
طلبوا بتعيين مستشار الخاص للتعامل مع برج
الجدي
رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي قبل ماكر في
شدد على ضروره ان يحقق الكونجرس مع الرئيس
فايدن بشان هذه الوثائق السريه التي عثر
عليها في منزله وذلك بعد انقلى بيض انه
يتعاون بشكل كامل مع مراجعه الوثائق
السريه
التي عثر عليها في منزل ومكتب الرئيس هو
شخص بقي في الحكومه لاكثر من 40 عاما هذا
الشخص كان حريصا جدا على النظر بامر وثائق
الرئيس ترامب والان نجد انه عندما كان
نائبا للرئيس احتفظ بالعديد من الوثائق
السريه باماكن مختلفه
جارد اعلنت عينه مستشار الخاص للتحقيق
لمسالته وجودي وثائق السريه
[موسيقى]
الحكم يسريه في منزل بادن وفي معهد ابحاث
مرتبط به بالرئيس ينتهك اي قوانين
معنا من واشنطن ناديه البيسي مراسله
العربيه الذي انت داخل البيت الابيض اذا
الان في حديقه البيت الابيض همم وعلى ما
اعتقد هناك مؤتمر صحفي ل البيت الابيض هل
هناك اي معطيات جديده حول هذه الوثائق
السريه الثانيه التي اكتشفت في منزل بايظ
هذه المره في دلاور
اهلا بك صهيب في الواقع قبل كريم جانبيه
التي المتوقع ان تكون كل الاسئله من
الصحفيه حول موضوع الوثائق السريه كان
هناك ايضا ايجاز من جون كوربي مناسبون
الاتصالات في البيت الابيض انا سالته عن
موضوع الرهائن في ايران همم في موضوع
مختلف يعني هو يركز على السياسه الخارجيه
لكن همم خلال دقائق القادمه اكيد
بدات الحديث نعم فعلا كما تقولين همم
نشاهد على الشاشه
تفضلي واصل لناديه
كنت اريد ان اقول حتى اريد ان استبرق ما
ستقوله هي لانها لم تعلق على هذا الموضوع
منذ الامس وهي محاصره من قبل الصحافيين
وتقول بانه هناك تحقيق في وزاره العدل
وهذا هو الاجراء المتبع من البيت الابيض
لن تستطيع ان تقول شيء اضافي في البدايه
قالت بانه ربما المحامي الخاص بالبيت
الابيض قال بانه تعاون مع المحققين مع
وزاره العدل مع الاف بي اي وانه بمجرد ما
اعرفه بهذا الوثائق همم سلموها الى
المقاطع
الجنسيه باسم الابيض
اركان
وزاره العدل
وقاموا باتخاذ خطوه صحيحه وهي تسليم
الوثائق وتعاونوا بشكل همم
قريب مع وزاره العدل وسماعنا اليوم
الفريق بعد اكتشاف الوثائق فورا
وهل سيكون هناك همم
الرئيس محمد
اكتشافهم لهذه الخطا وهو خطا الوقوع في
موضع وثائق سريه في مكان خاطئ وهناك تنسيق
مع وزاره العدل حول هذه المساله
كل الحوارات كانت عنا
الوثائق لكن في
وثائق 20 من ديسمبر كان هناك تركيز عليها
لماذا لا يوجد همم شفافيه هذه المساله
تتحدث عن الشفافيه همم
هذه المساله همم
التوجه الى وزاره
العدل وتنسيق التفتيش للتاكد
لان الوثائق موجوده في الجهه المختصره
وبعد انتهاء البحث يوم امس ليله امس تم
همم تصريح بعد التفتيش وكلها عمليه تابعه
لوزاره العدل
تحدث عن هذه المساله لابد ان يكون حضارين
في التعاون الكامل مع وزاره العدل
والتوفير التفاصيل
المناسبه كجزء من هذه العمل
نقطه اجابتك عليها
همم
البيت الابيض
الرئيس وفي غرف مجاوره وقال انها في منطقه
تخزين في
مكتبتي هل هذا هذه المساله ان شاء الله
لكن البحر كان ليله امس وانتهى والمساله
الان بين يدي وزاره العدل واذا ان اكون
واضحه كما كنا يوم امس
مساله حول التفاصيل
التي تجري الان امامكم في تفاصيلها
ماذا عن الغرفه
واي اسئله عن الاماكن التي وجدت فيها
الوثائق التي تتحدث عنها
ما قلته قبل قليل
تحدث عن انهم تفاجا وهمم عما في هذه
الوثائق همم
هل تفاجئ الرئيس ايضا من انها وثائق سريه
نعم نعم
الوثائق كانت موجوده هناك وهذا ما يسجل مع
اطلعناكم علي هذا الصباح وياخذ المساله
بيت الابيض على اسئله صحفيين البيبسي ما
تزال معنا من حديقه البيت الابيض يعني كما
توقعت ناديه يعني حصلت بسيل من الاسئله
فقط على الموضوع واحد الوثائق السريه في
منزل قالت ان تحقيق جاري وانها ستكون
وستلتزم بما تم الاعلان عنه المحامون
وجدوا هذه الوثائق وقاموا بالابلاغ طبعا
وزاره العدل يعني تتابع هذا الموضوع الاهم
همم على ما يبدو ناديه همم حديث على ان
همم بيض نفسه لا يعلم ان هذه الوثائق سريه
موجوده في منزله ماذا يعني ذلك هل يعني
القضيه يعني ليست همم مدبره ليست باعازم
من احد
لا هي ليست بايعاز من احد لكن هذه الحجه
التي يلجا اليها البيت الابيض بانه هذا
الخطا كان غير مقصود وغير متعمد على عكس
ما فعله الرئيس ترامب سابقا وبا ان الرئيس
لم يكن يعلم بوجود لنزكر بان هذه الوثائق
وجده عندما كان نائب للرئيس لم يكن رئيسا
ااه وقال بانه تفاجئ عندما وجد محامو هذه
الوثائق بالاضافه الى وثائق خاصه تتعلق
بجنازه ابني وغيرها تخص العائله يعني لكن
على كل حال كنت اتحدث على همم المشكله
امام البيت الابيض الانيا ليست فقط بانه
همم بانهم ابلغ وزاره العدل بوجود هذه
الوثائق عندما اكتشفه على الفور لكن
المشكله الاساسي هي شفافيه بانهم كانوا
يدركونا منذ بدايه نوفمبر قبل ايام من
الانتخابات النصفيه للكونغرس وتكتم على
الموضوع وهذا البيت الابيض الديمقراطي يضع
موضوع
الشفافيه في اعلى سلم الاولويات اذا
الرئيس تعرض الى حرج كبير جدا كيف يمكن ان
يدافع
عن رجاءا
همم في حالنا اذا اثبت التحقيق انه هذه ان
بايدون يوجه يواجهتهما جنائيه في مساله
الوثائق السريه التي احتفظ بها هل يمكن ان
يعزل الرئيس بايدا
ب سيطالبون بالبدايه بلجنه التحقيق ثم
سيطالبون بعزله تماما كما سمعنا من
الديمقراطيا عندما كانت رئيس الان سنسمع
من الجمهوريين وبعدين هو الرئيس الان في
البيت الابيض
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك ناديه بلبيسي مراسله
العربيه مباشره كنت معنا من حديقه البيت
الابيض
[موسيقى]
افادت وكاله الانباء الفلسطينيه بمقتل شاب
واصابه اخر برصاص القوات الاسرائيليه
اثناء اقتحامها لبلده قباطيه جنوبي جنين
في الضفه الغربيه وقالت وزاره الصحه ان
الشاب المتوفي اصيب برصاصه في راسه بينما
نقل المصاب الى المستشفى في حاله حرجه
ووفقا للوكاله الفلسطينيه اين القوات
الاسرائيليه حصلت منزله احد المواطنين في
البلده ما ادى الى اندلاع مواجهات
صدقت الهيئه العامه للكنيسه الاسرائيلي
بالقراءه التمهيديه على مشروع قانوني سحب
المواطنه او الاقامه من اي اسير فلسطيني
من القدس او الداخل تلقى تعويضات ماليه من
السلطه الفلسطينيه
قانون الاسرائيليون جديد اقر بشكل مبدئي
ينص على سحب الجنسيه والمواطنه من اي
فلسطينيه في القدس او الداخل اعتقل على
خلفيه امنيه وتلقى مساعده ماليه من السلطه
الفلسطينيه
القانون يعتبر جزءا من خطه وزير الامن
القومي ثمار بن جبير والذي كان قد تعهد
بتغيير نمط الحياه الانسانيه والتنظيميه
للاسرى الفلسطينيين في السجون اذا اخذنا
بعين الاعتبار مثلا القدس التي دائما تحت
المركز الصداره في عدد المعتقلين يعني
عمليه تهويد واخلاق وتفريغ عمليه تهجير
جماعي وزير الامن القومي بنجبير كان قد
زار سجن نافحه واطلق بعدها سلسله تصريحات
بدات تترجم على ارض الواقع من ابرزها
تنقلات واسعه في الاقسام بناء اقسام جديده
في السجون اصغر حجما لمنع التجمعات
التنظيميه تهديدات بمنع فتره الاستراحه
الجماعيه ومنع الاهالي من ادخال المساعدات
الماليه لذويهم وسحب الكثير من الامتيازات
التي حققها الاسرى في السجون السابقه
اجراءات من شانها ان تفجر مواجهه كبرى
خارج اسوار السجون تهدد بها حركه فتح في
الضفه وحماس في غزه سنكون
فيه واي معركه شعبنا الفلسطيني لافشاء
المخططات من غفير وحكومه اليمين المتطرفه
لن تكون كسابقاتها والعروس يتحمل نتائج اي
معركه القادمه ويقطعوا في السجون
الاسرائيليه نحو اربعه الاف 5400 اسير
منهم 600 اسير مريض ونحو 20 اسيرا معتقلين
منذ نحو 30 عاما وتعتبر قضيه الاسرى من
القضايا القليله الباقيه التي تتمتع
باجماع وطني يتجاوز الانقسام وخلافات
الفصائل نقل الاسرى ان اداره السجون
ابلغتهم انها قد لا توافق على بعض
الاجراءات لكنها مضطره لتنفيذها بقرار من
الوزير
فرد الاسرى انه حال تنفيذ هذه الاجراءات
سيلجاون الى العصيان والتمرد قبل استعمال
السلاح الاخير المتمثل بالاضراب العام عن
الطعام من قباله سجن عوفر الاسرائيلي عبد
الحفيظ جعوان العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
وبعد قليل في اخبار الساعه نجاح وعمليه
فصل التوام السيامي العراقيه علي وعمر في
السعوديه
[موسيقى]
العائله الملكيه في بريطانيا
لاول مره منذ نشر مذكرات الامير هاري التي
اثار جدلا كبيره
في اسكتلندا حيث وجد استقبال حارا هذا ولم
ترد العائله الملكيه على الاتهامات التي
تضمنها كتاب هاري كما ان العديد من
المصادر تستبعد قيامها بذلك
ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
جاسم بمشاركه 27 من الاستشاريين
والاختصاصيين والكوادر التمريضيه والفنيه
وذلك بمستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي
للاطفال بمدينه الملك عبد العزيز الطبيه
للحرس الوطني
لتوجيهات خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود واولي عهده
اخبارها الدكتور عبد الله ربيعه والفريق
الطبي كامل انه وضعهم مستقر والحمد لله
وانهم بصحه جيده وان شاء الله بس منتظرين
للافارقه وشكر جزيل للدكتور عبد الله
الربيع ولطاقم الطبي كاملا وشكري وامتناني
الى الملك
والى الملك سلمان والى ولي عهده الامين
محمد بن سلمان والى الشعب السعودي كافه
الذي تفاعل معنا شكرا جزيلا
اخبار الساعه ايضا لهذا الخميس انتهى شكرا
لكم على المشاهده نعود ونلتقي في اخبار
الساعه يوم الاحد باذن الله اللقاء
[موسيقى]